MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
Gentlemen, It is my pleasure
to bring a phenomenal talent,
an amazing talent, and a
beautiful talent, Margot B.
[MUSIC -- Margot B, "Cool"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC --
MARGOT B, "Complete"]
[APPLAUSE]
MARGOT B: Thank you guys.
Enjoy the rest of the show.
RYAN: Hello Margot.
MARGOT B: Hi Ryan.
RYAN: Thanks for being
here tonight.
I'm really excited
to have you.
MARGOT B: Thanks
for having me.
This is fun to be at Google.
RYAN: Yeah, totally.
So just wanted to talk to you
a little bit about your
background and a little
bit about your music.
And then we'll get started.
So could you tell people about
you that might not know who
you are, about your music,
your background.
MARGOT B: Sure.
I grew up in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
I come from a very eclectic
family, my mother who is
Russian, German and my father,
originally from Jamaica, and
moved to the United States
when he was 16.
So he has an interesting
story.
And then they met in college
and produced
me, which is great.
I'm thankful.
And I've lived in New York
for five years, working
independently as a singer,
songwriter and working as a
songwriter for other
artists and
touring with other artists.
I just finished Rent
off Broadway.
It just closed in September.
And doing other shows
in the meantime but
getting back to my music.
So it's exciting.
RYAN: Cool.
If you could quickly summarize
your experience with Rent, how
would you say that?
Or what would you say?
MARGOT B: Life changing.
It was something that I
will always remember.
And I never expected it to be
so hard to say goodbye.
But that family is such
a huge family.
Rent was such an unbelievable
show that totally changed the
face of musical theater for
Rock and everything and
changing the way that it's sung
and the way that it just
looks to everyone.
And as a kid, I grew
up with that show.
So it's kind of weird to be
doing book reports when you
were younger and then be in the
show and sitting with the
director and the writer's father
and being invited over
to the family dinners.
And it was life changing.
RYAN: Cool.
Yeah, I was lucky enough
to get to see you.
MARGOT B: Yeah, we had a lot
of fun jumping around and
swinging from the rafters.
RYAN: Yeah, you did very well.
MARGOT B: Thanks.
RYAN: Very good.
So let me ask you a little bit
about Black History Month and
what it means to you.
MARGOT B: Sure.
RYAN: We're here to celebrate
that tonight.
So just a little bit, maybe,
more about your heritage and
how you've celebrated
over the years.
I heard you wrote a tribute to
Martin Luther King when you
were 13 that still is
kind of relevant.
MARGOT B: I did.
RYAN: So I think it's really
cool that you're here tonight.
MARGOT B: It was really funny,
just to kind of touch on that
story a little bit.
My mother and I were driving
to Philadelphia
for a beauty pageant.
Because I really wanted to be a
part of everything that they
were a part of.
Because they were doing a lot
of fund raising and a lot of
volunteer work.
And I thought that's awesome.
I get to do that all the time?
That sounds like a great idea.
I want to win this thing.
So I went to Philly
with my mom.
And when we were in the
car, I just got bored.
And I used to write poems and
songs every once in awhile.
But she suggested that
we just write a song.
And she asked me, what's
really important.
And it happened to be
Black History Month.
And I was like, why don't we
write it about Doctor Martin
Luther King Junior.
And she was like, that sounds
like a great idea.
So we sat down.
Well, obviously she
was driving.
But I sat down and just tried
to brainstorm a little bit.
And she helped me kind of
think and figure out my
thoughts and process it and kind
of put it into song form.
And now it's played in every
state in the US on his
birthday, which is
really exciting.
And we did a whole video.
And I incorporated
my high school.
And we got out for the day,
which was really cool as a kid
to kind of play hooky for a
day in school and shoot my
music video.
And then that played along
with the song.
And that kind of gave me, like,
a little bit of a claim.
But it was all for the
right reasons.
And it was just because
it meant a lot to me.
And coming from such eclectic
background with my ethnicity,
and my family, and religion,
and everything, it was just
really important to me to put
out that message and know that
it's still really relevant
though it doesn't seem like
things are so restricted now.
We've come very far.
But I think that we still have
many, many moons to go before
the face of color is
kind of extinct.
But it was really exciting for
me to kind of add to a little
piece of the puzzle as
best as I could.
RYAN: Yeah, I think
that's incredible.
It's really commendable.
I know when I was playing hooky,
I was shooting monsters
on video games.
MARGOT B: I might have done
that on the side, maybe.
RYAN: So I think it's really
good to have you because your
background is so different.
And you appreciate Black
History Month.
And also you give back.
And I wanted to talk a little
bit about you've
volunteered a lot.
And you did a lot for Katrina
in Pittsburgh.
And I just wanted to see what
you've done and what
you're doing now.
MARGOT B: Yeah, volunteering has
just always been something
that my heart has drawn to.
We did a Katrina benefit concert
in one of the biggest
arenas in Pittsburgh, which
granted me a key to the city
from the mayor of Pittsburgh,
which was really cool.
And I was 15.
So that was really nice.
The Red Cross collaborated
with us.
And my mom and dad and brother
helped me put it together.
And it was really exciting.
We had huge names put it all
together in Pittsburgh.
And we had thousands
of people there.
It was huge.
And we raised a lot of money
for the benefit.
Since I was in Rent, I had the
opportunity to collaborate
with Friends In Deed, which was
what Rent was based off of
and written because of
the support groups
dealing with AIDS.
And I dealt a lot with their
main headquarters out of Soho.
And it was really--
it was actually around the same
time that my grandmother
passed, so it was really near
and dear to my heart.
And now they've opened up their
doors to not only AIDS
survivors or people that have
lost friends or family and, or
family with the AIDS virus but
to also cancer survivors and
people that were lost.
So I had the opportunity
to do that.
And I do the AIDS
Walk every year.
And I just started with City
Harvest, which is a great
organization out of Brooklyn.
It's a bit of a truck.
But it's really worth it.
We recently were there because
of the theater and Broadway
community as well I was invited,
which was amazing.
I've had a lot of great
experiences.
We packed patches of potatoes,
and oranges, and pears.
And then they go out to
families in need.
And we packed over a ton.
So each sack full of pear or
whatever it is feeds a family.
So that was really nice to know
that we fed over a couple
hundred families within
a couple hours.
And it was fun and exciting.
And I just had the opportunity
to be invited to a Women Who
Care event hosted
by Loreen Arbus.
And it is based off of the UCP
Foundation, which is the
United Cerebral Palsy
Foundation.
So I'm excited to get
on board with them.
But all of these organizations
are really important to me.
So I'm just trying
to find new ones.
RYAN: Yeah, you're staying
connected and getting involved
with the community.
MARGOT B: Yeah, you got
to get involved or
else nothing changes.
RYAN: Cool.
So let's switch gears a little
bit, talk about music.
What's next for you?
And then we'll get going.
MARGOT B: Well, I'm pumped to
get back on the music train.
I've been writing a lot and
collaborating with a lot of
different producers, and
writers, and musicians, and
just trying to open my mind to
as many possibilities as I
possibly can.
I've come across a lot of
talented people within my
short term of a career.
And I just keep opening
more and more doors.
And I don't know how
it's happening.
But I'm really blessed.
So I'm back in the studio
writing and hopefully busting
out so new stuff.
And you can definitely check
me around the city.
Because I am booking shows
everywhere around
the city right now.
And I just can't wait to get
back on stage just with my
group and do my thing.
And I hope people like it.
RYAN: Cool.
Well I'm sure they will.
Margot, if anyone could do
anything, it's Margo.
She puts her mind to something
and it happens.
MARGOT B: Thank you.
That's really nice.
RYAN: So thanks for
being here.
We're really looking forward
to having you here.
MARGOT B: Thanks.
RYAN: And good luck
with everything.
MARGOT B: Thank you.